so donald trump has essentially ruled
out that mike pence would be his vice
presidential running mate if he were to
run for president again in 2024 and this
is not particularly surprising given
the last 14 months of the things that
donald trump has said about mike pence
but it does make 2024
significantly more interesting a
president running again after losing
re-election with a different running
mate is
interesting and this we have learned um
thanks to an interview that donald trump
gave to the washington examiner earlier
this week washington examiner uh writing
trump now in this i know washington
examiner is not what we typically use as
a source but this is the primary source
here this was an interview that they did
trump says pence partnership over as
ex-president eyes 2024 comeback bid
former president donald trump is
effectively ruling out ruling out
tapping former vp mike pence as his
running mate should he mount a third
white house bid in 2024 and win the
republican nomination quote i don't
think the people would accept it
trump told the washington examiner
tuesday evening during a telephone
interview that he gave from mar-a-lago
the former president cited friction
stemming from the aftermath of the 2020
election it's funny to call it friction
you tried to get the guy to do something
illegal
describing that as friction is
interesting suggesting their differences
are too stark to overcome i would agree
with that
trump claimed the contest was stolen and
wanted pence to overturn the results
during the congressional certification
of biden's victory he can't
pence who in his capacity as senate
president was presiding over the
certification proceedings refused
explaining the constitution granted him
no authority it's interesting to call it
a refusal it's really an inability he
can't do it he can't do it now as the
article says and as trump said
trump continues to insist otherwise
he pointed to bipartisan talks on
capitol hill to reform the electoral
count act the law governing the
congressional certification we've talked
about that already
trump said mike and i had a great
relationship except for the very
important factor that took place at the
end we had a very good relationship i
haven't spoken to him
in a long time
now there's a couple different things uh
that that can be talked about here first
we're upping the uniqueness uniqueness
factor in some sense because if trump
runs he would also run he will have run
after losing and pick a different vp
it'll be interesting from like a
historical perspective
i also
can't
avoid saying that the danger factor
would likely be greater because trump
could pick someone that might be more
assertive
and more dangerous and more useful to
him trump is
reportedly mad at florida governor ron
desantis right now but imagine if trump
partnered up with desantis who is
much more delusional than pence in a
particular way and i would argue much
more assertive and able to get things
done
pence
has
conceded that he didn't have the ability
to overturn the election and that was a
nice enough to put him on trump's
naughty list now for mike pence's part
he was on maria bartoromo's fox business
show not that long ago on march 8th and
she asked him about what are you
thinking for 24 do you want to see trump
run and here's how pence answered it mr
vice president before you go
a word on 2024 do you want president
trump to run are you looking to get back
into leadership
you know all of my focus right now is on
2022 i think we have a historic
opportunity
to reclaim majorities in the house and
the senate to elect great republican
governors
around america and in 2023 i'm i'm
confident the republican party uh will
nominate a candidate who will be
the next president of the united states
of america and at the right time my
family and i will reflect and consider
how we might participate
in that process but yeah so not really
answering the question i think of note
or how the betting markets are looking
at this so far if you look that predict
it
right now
39 cents of every dollar are being bet
on trump being the republican nominee
very close at this point 27 cents of
every dollar are behind ron desantis
being the republican nominee
and in a pretty distant fourth place are
six cents on the dollar
behind mike pence being
the eventual republican nominee i think
there is almost no chance in hell that
mike pence ends up as the republican
nominee but needless to say
it'll be an interesting 2024.
one of our sponsors today is emmy the
world's first low carb high protein 100
percent plant-based instant ramen imme
has only six net carbs perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb unlike regular
ramen it has 21 grams of protein helping
you feel fuller longer
18 grams of fiber that's four times more
than most other ramen brands and emmy
also has 35 percent less sodium than
competitors so you don't get that bloat
and thirst
me uses only high quality ingredients
they don't use a lot of preservatives
that many other ramen brands use i love
making imi ramen as a snack just like
any other instant ramen you put it in
the microwave ready in a few minutes i
love adding green onion and mushrooms to
it yummy comes in spicy beef tom yum
shrimp black garlic chicken i've tried
all three they're all delicious and
they're plant-based right now emmy is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below